[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
this is a quick review of the j-bird x3
the super portable Bluetooth wireless
earbuds connected by a wire unlike the
more expensive and also delayed Apple
earpods
the X threes are definitely an
incremental improvement to the X 2's
which makes sense because it's not like
there's smartphones where there's new
features to add every year so these will
be very familiar to those of you who
have seen the X 2's or even the original
jaybird bluebloods X which is fine
because those are also both pretty good
so first off the new shape is different
it's a bit of a new design if you look
at these earbuds they're a bit smaller
in volume than last year with the X 2's
and they're a bit shorter and also a bit
lighter which helps with comfort and the
most important part of this back is that
they're now flat on the back so the X
threes are now what I'll call hat proof
so while the X 2's had a sort of a
rounded bulbous back that would stick
out of your ears more the X 3 buds stick
out a bit less and they don't get caught
as easily so if you have like a winter
hat to put on over the top of your
earbuds that works better or if you ride
like a motorcycle I needed to go under a
helmet this new design helps a lot with
that too and then the shape of the fins
as well which I do use are also slightly
more curved which helps with the fit and
they were already pretty good at not
falling out of my ear but this helps
even more and the sort of passive
seagull that it forms over your ear is
extremely good even with the rubber tips
that I use but as you can see they do
come with both the rubber tips in
different sizes and the comply foam that
molds to your ear and gives you an even
better seal there also again this soft
touch plastic finish instead of the
glossy from the originals which again
I'll take matte black wherever I can get
it Plus now there's a little bit more
metal to bolster the build quality the
previous buds were actually pretty
durable already as I've mentioned and as
an athlete I'll take any enhancements to
the build I can get there fully sweat
and water resistant again you can beat
them up take them out on the sand take
them to the track wherever they can
definitely hang now they technically
have new drivers inside a new six
millimeter driver with a more of a
cone-shaped cylinder housing listening
to the x2 and x3 back to back I can only
hear a bit of a difference I say the
biggest difference I heard and sound
with the x3 s is this slightly wider
soundstage like a little
better instrument separation which is
cool to hear but overall the sound
profile from the X 3s lows mids and
highs are very similar to the familiar X
to s if not a little bit more detailed
but obviously these can't be audiophile
grade comments I mean I'm not an
audiophile I'm streaming you know
Spotify music or Bluetooth audio from my
phone to wireless earbuds so it's
everyday use they sound great what you
can now do though is use the my sound
app to change the sound signature with
these so I already think they happen to
have one of the best flat sound
signatures of any wireless pair of
headphones but now just like you could
with the freedoms you can adjust the
firmware of the earbud to follow it
around from device to device so you can
build your own shape of a sound profile
you can name it and save it or you can
pick from a ton of free pre-built ones
or community based ones all these sound
signatures to choose from so that's
pretty dope so the one thing that can be
considered either an upside or a
downside or both is the new controller
and battery instead of being built into
the earbud itself now the battery is in
the controller so you will still get
roughly 8 hours of streaming battery
life which is on the high end of what
you can get out of any wireless earbud
but now the charging method is this
little cradle thing here with the pins
it works fine you line up the pins and
click it into place and start charging
like that it's full size USB so it works
pretty much anywhere the original did
but now the downside here is you can't
forget this little charger cable you got
to remember to bring this thing on trips
if you lose it you're kind of stranded
because you can't just plug the
headphones right into a cable like you
could before so yeah a bit of a mixed
bag here that you now require this
little cradle to charge I guess I
consider that the biggest downside and
then for what I would consider to be the
biggest upside in my opinion of the new
j-bert X 3s is the price so when the
jaybird X 2's were first launched they
were about 170 $9.99 for most places
they're pretty premium but for what
you're getting for the price a plus
you've seen a review I really liked them
then the jaybird freedoms came out and
they were $1.99 99 you know a little bit
more expensive and they're starting to
encroach on some other high-end
headphones so I'm not as likely to
recommend that to everyone but you kind
of might have expected the jaybird X 3s
to follow suit well they don't these X
threes are launching at 120 999
that's already a great price for an
improvement over the headphones that
launched for 180 bucks so that's dope
Thank You j-bird for that and then again
one of my favorite things about when
they launch new headphones is the old
ones go down in price so now you can get
the X 2's for somewhere around 80 bucks
so I'll leave a link to both of those
pairs of headphones right below that
like button if you want to check them
out and maybe get yourself into some
wireless audio for the holiday season
the price I think is awesome I'll leave
a link to the freedoms as well I did a
full review on them I don't recommend
them as much as I recommend these I
definitely prefer these but if you're
curious I'll leave that too and that's
pretty much it thanks for watching this
review and also for those who have been
asking and curious yes the Google pixel
review and the iphone 7 review are both
upcoming give me a second that's been it
thank you for watching I'll talk to you
guys the next one peace
[Music]